hey annie you know what's crazy what
we're beautiful hilarious stand-up
comedians on tour i mean it's it's
heaven i can't believe this happened i
love our fans they're incredible i meet
them i've signed so many breasts me too
i have signed so many i've signed esther
merch i've signed breasts i've signed
annie merch
bring us your titties bring it we will
sign whatever like any parts of you that
you want um i know i'm going to
indianapolis in march 17th to 19th and
i'm going to philly oh my gosh
hey my philly people go see my girl
you're going to like it i'm going to san
diego austin brooklyn chicago go to
esteronice.com for tickets annie where
are you going okay i'm going to be at
the brea improv on march 3rd it's one
night only so come see me i'm going to
bring some friends it's going to be
crazy wild and very fun definitely doing
a meet and greet afterwards i'll be in
richmond virginia
at the sandman comedy club that's march
12th
10th and 12th 212th i'm going to be in
las vegas i hope you can come there with
me las vegas san francisco
back to florida and dania beach i'll be
in burbank at flappers i'm doing a one
night or june 11th or june 18th as well
i can't wait for us to continue to meet
our fans and it's been amazing just go
to annie letterman dot com shows and
esther on ice to see our dates
[Music]
i wouldn't say something about brandon
wardell what
not only was he the perfect choice to
sit in because
he's the exact dna matches me
but he made so many good points about
like catholic upbringing and also i had
an epiphany brandon wardell
is the brother i've never [ __ ]
there's still time
oh he's only one of three he's a special
one
there's still time you said there's
still time baby
how long's bobby gone should i should i
show him
where did bobby come back
why is he the brother you've never felt
he feels like a relative like i i really
i look at someone like him and i'm like
i don't need to read the fine print of
his life i know exactly what kind of boy
he is thank you for this andres yeah
these are delicious i feel like you're
trying to seduce us
i love that i would love more of that
that would be great
i have an announcement to make and i
think something is wrong with me are you
tan
i think no i put a lot of them okay you
look before your announcement i just
want to say i think you look beautiful
we love the outfit we haven't seen in a
while for you to come back so hot it's
really good could have covid because
jules went to a [ __ ] college party
what and came home with kovid is she
joel says
is she a college kid she's a college kid
and she's been cast away downstairs
she's not allowed to come upstairs like
us usually at the house she gets treated
like a regular guy
exactly there's always fall covered
protocols at your place
it's weird
you have to take care of the vicious
dogs now i do
i do but something happened because i've
been monitoring my symptoms because i'm
like okay i've been exposed to jules
just a little bit right not too much
because she went to the party when i was
not there um but then the last three
days like i've i've never been hornier
in my life so i'm like is this kovet
she's like she's like
cove that you think maybe is a it's a
symptom of kova to be extra horny i
think so is that on the list
i'm trying to think of how i felt when
yeah annie you had it tell us i you know
what it you know what when you get the
test result because i'm i have a cold
now and i didn't it came back negative
my result my test results but we also if
you just had kova you couldn't have it
right right now who knows nobody knows
who told you that nobody has anything
nobody knows a thing
i don't remember being i just remember
getting a spray tan like i remember just
being like it's weird i have a spray tan
and i'm so sick right now
there's like an extra shame when your
test result comes back nega or positive
you're like oh i have a different type
of sickness than usual that is true
because you're almost too hot to be sick
well that is like i feel like literally
it makes sense as like an from an
animalistic perspective because when
you're tan you appear healthy
and that doesn't go alliant along with
being sick and i had my eyelashes i mean
i looked amazing
have you
have you ever had sex while um with a
fever
no but i've read on reddit like
that there's couples that when they're
both sick they'll have sex and i'm like
i can't even imagine it i'm so
uncomfortable when i'm sick like have
you done that how do you i have what is
that it wasn't it was the flu and the
the your internal temperature is so hot
and his dick is so hot so there is
something kind of cool about it it's
like an ice pack
a penis ice pack but it is really um
it's not comfortable but it is different
experience i like that there's like so
many like crusty tissues but you can't
tell if it's snot or jizz
oh speaking of jizz i have
i have a trash tank idea i'm listening
and this isn't just an idea i think that
we should actually sell this i wanna i
wanna remind everyone trash tank is our
version of shark tank and it's where we
pitch business ideas that feel like they
fit in with the theme of our of our
empire of trash tuesday i don't know if
this will um
give us an empire but i think it'll give
us a few extra dollars okay so
i think about when i have sex and the
most inconvenient thing afterwards is if
he's like a a big [ __ ] blaster
it it just and he doesn't have like the
hot towel ready i mean if he does have
the hot towel already that's weird um if
he hasn't like rolled like you're at a
[ __ ] chinese restaurant you're like
wait imagine before you even but you get
to the house you don't even know that
you're gonna [ __ ] but the hot towel is
ready it has one of those like warmers
that they have at the spa
hospital hospitals they have this warmer
you go to a nice hospital
what hospital are you going to that
beautiful nice
surprising thing ever annie goes to a
bad hospital
well in santa fe our hospital used to be
we call it st victims because we're like
oh my god that's the hospital we have to
go to
okay um so i was thinking he doesn't
have his warm towel i've been wiped down
by kitchen rags
i've been wiped down by a fake like
plant a fake leaf from a plant like
anything in the vicinity i've been
waiting in here why are we playing
did you bang in my chair would be on
order wait you got sex in here after the
episode's over or a dirty sock you know
boys are just filthy right and i think
that not all of them are very
smart um when they have [ __ ] brain so i
think we should make designated [ __ ] rags
with embroidered lettering on it that
says come right oh my god trash tuesday
[ __ ] rags okay it's the cutest thing i've
ever heard okay i'm i like where they're
supposed to be like um the ones that
they use in the olympics they're like
squeegee ones i'm talking about the ones
that are what are they called for divers
yeah yeah yeah the chamois
i always use a t-shirt because it it
comes you guys don't have a [ __ ] rag for
my nyquil i just got on my shirt okay
annie is just
gulping down dayquil
it doesn't have to be
extra points that it has your jizz on it
oh god he has a family annie maybe it's
what well we know how he made that
family and we'd like to see it
we'd like to see i think that people
like i shouldn't be speculating on
pete's [ __ ] oh god sorry what's setting
them apart though from just any other
towel are they going to be extra soft
like think about it well look we're
three hot [ __ ] what would we like to be
wiped down with oops
okay it's like microfiber
is just silk look
annie is right i think it has to have a
chamois element because that's the most
absorbent what is chamois a chamois is
like it's almost like plasticky it's
like a squishy material and it just
really takes all the liquid off and it
kind of pops out it's almost like a
beauty blender yeah like a yes
this is the kind of innovation that we
need to bring to this we got to make
these fast because these people are
going to steal from oh no no no i didn't
have an idea for a name i said i wanted
to keep the name yeah and i thought of
one okay
in all the comments everyone's like
they're such pick me girls but okay are
we the pygmy girls what if we're just
the pikmi pod
i like that it's definitely intriguing
to me
we're not trying to get boys legos but i
just feel like we're so opposite of
pikmi girls because we're literally
like
telling the world about our utis and
like our molestations and like like it's
not do you consider the uti equal to our
molestation
your own body body's molesting you
tickling you inside i mean actually it's
very similar i do think that my uti was
more traumatic it's inside for me it was
for carlos too
oh i want to actually bring something up
this involves carlos i have a theory
that esther's tweets are actually just
meant to be text to carlos
can you pull up esther's twitter real
quick
i i only looked at one but i'm pretty
sure all of them have this element wait
you're right because i think the last
one was does anyone know where my
computer is yeah my laptop is it's like
these could all just go to directly to
carlos that's right i saw you tweet at
me last night
oh i just was retweeting what she said i
said check carlos's anus
it's very chewy to tweet i think it's
what it's chugi it's what's
for old people yeah to tweet at all yeah
i think it's lame to tweet so when i say
esther's the only one that tweets out of
this crew i look i'm doing it my own way
i'm saying hey does anyone on twitter
know where my laptop is
there's nothing chewy about that you're
really taking advantage of them you're
going i really want to take your time
for nothing i really want to make sure i
need all my fans
rudy on on rudy would covet as a savage
everyone everyone in my family jules so
everyone in my family is like oh my god
that was a great halftime show with
snoop with dr dre and she's like and
like a savage she was like i'm sorry but
if you thought that was good you're a
chug and if you're defending them you're
a tube what is fully
old
jewels is wow jules and carlos are the
same age
not but carlos isn't so that's the weird
part he's like carlos how are you
getting this end i learned from this
girl i dated in the summer who is 25.
really can we meet him i mean
we have them and her on what's funny is
i learned chugi from her gay roommates
so it's not even really her was her
roommate like just come in my room let's
get over here carlos
i appreciate your bald head more than
her i've heard chugi on tick tock yeah
is a very um
it's
that would hurt me if someone called me
chugi i think but also should we just
embrace what we are maybe because we are
past a certain age you know i maybe
women passed a certain age maybe that's
a new podcast
where for the content is for the world
but yeah
i don't know i think about it all the
time where it's like
are we just like fighting or like
shouldn't we just be like enjoying the
world through the eyes of the age we are
i agree i think though i almost think
that chugi is doesn't mean you're older
it's like it's some of the things
it's the things around that age range
that arch like to like harry potter is
chugi so it's like i don't think any of
us are choogie
right what if i like pulled out like oh
no
no here's oh really
you quibble i don't know
someone said i can't read so you're
never gonna get me on books
someone on twitter said if you use um
neutrogena makeup white what makeup
wipes you're a tube
that's me i used one today i have them
on my [ __ ] oh god that's not sorry we
did a shoe last night you had makeup on
your [ __ ] yeah we did a shoot i had a
breakout so
um so yeah apparently the halftime show
is chewy it was listen the halftime show
was fun because it brought us back to a
time
i mean the lip syncing was off the whole
time but we were just weren't going to
say anything i just think that i don't
care i'm fine with people i was like fun
up there worried for 50 cents like
medical needs at the moment
his airway was constricted like somebody
just flipped them don't let him hang
like i liked him hanging i said keep him
hanging like that upside down the whole
time
when he flipped i went come on you [ __ ]
stay the whole time
and eminem looks so funny with his just
for men beard i am not hilarious
it's colored in like my eyebrows right
now it's like did you not get to your
threader in time what's your excuse i
think i didn't see this super bowl
halftime show but how could it be
anything near as good as [ __ ] was that
when you took a break because you were
so into the football yeah you're like oh
the football and i'm gonna take a break
hi yeah i needed a rest so you thought
shakira was the best
yeah show ever yes
did you not no i thought the best of all
time that really moved me was prince it
was just him prince was amazing in the
rain
and
yeah i nothing will ever compete with i
got very horny i hooked up with someone
out that night yeah me too
i watched that at my friend's house i
just started taking an improv class and
it was my first starting comedy in
philadelphia
and i had no friends i took the improv
class with my dad which is so
embarrassing wait whoa that's how few
friends i had i moved back to
philadelphia i was like i want to do
comedy you're a loser i googled i know
you were a loser are you a little
jealous you didn't think of it first yes
you're a youtuber oh this is the biggest
loser thing i've ever done and she took
swim lessons with her mom abuse me no my
mom crashed our swim
my mom just joined the swim team i was
like how did you get that in your size
that swimsuit
no give it to me beat me beat me with it
you went to improv with your i just
that's so embarrassing and nerdy and
weird the whole thing and my dad was so
sexual in the class
your dad would be an improv is exactly
how my dad was like dads are like let's
just make a [ __ ] joke you're like what
the hell
my dad was 60 years older than everyone
in the class he was 60 years their elder
and everything was like i got a boner
like come on dad the suggestion was eggs
but we did the class together
i know kind of
but we did the class together and then
um i had no friends and i was literally
like will anyone be friends with me i
have no friends were you embarrassed at
the time or did you think it was funny
and like that he was doing that stuff
did you have it it was both i mean i
liked him coming because i loved my i'm
not coming
not that way except i would be happy for
him if he could still do that that would
be great
so you you liked being there with him i
did but it was both it was both
it was like fun to hang out with my dad
and humiliating to be in the class with
him but then it's an improv class
everyone's the dork but so i became
friends with this one guy was like all
right i'll hang out with you and i was
like thank you and then he was like my
friends are having a super bowl party so
i went over and we were watching the
halftime show
and he had said something about how his
younger brother had used his computer
and when he was searching his computer
the next day his his brother he found
his brother's adult profile finder or
his profile on adultfinder.com or
whatever and he found all these pictures
of his brother's dick he had uploaded
from his computer so the halftime show
hit and i went hey do you want to go
upstairs and show me your brother's deck
that was my line
and then we had a fun time
i think you see it
uh no i just saw his dick i saw his own
deck and i'm sure they were looked the
same they're very similar brother
brothers maybe you would know
i actually meant more from just like you
seem like the medical
wise person like if do if there's
brothers do are there dicks the same
i've never [ __ ] brothers i [ __ ] my
brothers but i've never talked about the
time again there's still time wait does
brian wardell have a brother
who knows i want to tell you guys
something crazy i did what
i as we all knew
i lost my sunglasses
so i had to re-buy them you lost this
elite i lost this when and where i lost
them a week ago i bought these a week
minus one day ago
i bought them immediately after because
i was like i'm not gonna where'd you go
i got them at bloomingdale's and then
the other day
i found my
i found my salines ah
so now are we doing a giveaway
or you're just wearing double i'll give
them to carlos but they cost seven
hundred dollars
because they touched my face
oh they went up in value
they've gone up in values
what is it
465 at bloomingdale's yeah
so guys i'm wearing 1k rent
on my face damn
i just went to bloomingdale's and got a
balenciaga wallet
i got the balenciaga goggles but i had
that kim kardashian's been wearing but
you got those yes but they do they look
like seasick
the ones like how much are they 400
everything's 400.
everything's around for them some are
800. okay
we this brings me to a conversation that
we need to have as your business manager
andy i need to teach you about something
and it's called inflation
and we're experiencing it
very heavily right now
and i'm it's not i hate it explain it i
don't know what it is i don't know how
to explain it
what
i extra padded them for you guys no
maybe there is something fun we can do
with the second pair
yeah we can do a celine giveaway a
saleen giveaway oh yeah is there a way
we can like i thought they were mine
no no you would have to pay so much
money for them it's like oh they went
okay that was real okay that's for you
yeah we know how much we never looked
into a camera before
what's funny is that after this ends
carlos is gonna approach you outside and
be like i'll give you 700.
i almost bought them in new york i know
he did try them on yeah it almost goes i
think they do look good
they look good on everyone i think
honestly i think i have a gift and that
is finding glasses that look good on
everyone i mean i can't argue against
you yeah but you have a face that like
you're like my sister you have a face
that just
all things look good on it it's okay
that's including thank you so listen
that's so sweet of you
i thank you so much for saying that it's
incorrect
it's so sweet it's so kind i i want you
to like take the compliment i love you
it is so incorrect i my face is so wide
that sunglasses go out on me like their
children's glasses all the time like
when i wear the clown glasses it looks
like a little funny not that funny and
hats like
like a regular ball cap like right here
is where it starts to come out it goes
here so it curves out like this but
thank you you wouldn't know a thing
about wide face disaster
me yeah i'm round i'm a perfect circle
my dad used to say i'm a bowling ball
why because he stuck all his fingers in
you
everyone laughed too hard at that
everyone in the room because we know
it's a joke and we don't think your dad
molested you
and that if we all were very quiet
that's when you're worried
i'm gonna just say something
i have amazing hair
you do i really do why do you have
amazing hair esther because i use
neutrophil and also because i'm jewish
but
neutral helps me for real listen when i
turned 30 and my hormones went all out
of whack my hair started falling out of
my head it's so crazy because nobody
tells you that this is going to happen
you only hear about guys balding you
never hear about girls like hair
thinning and stuff and you see all these
women getting older cutting their hair
short and stuff and now i get it well
you don't have to if you take neutral i
take it every day ass adjusted it's not
an overnight fix and i am telling you
guys i have seen a difference my sister
takes it she was having the same problem
this stuff really works yeah
go ahead no i'm just gonna say i put my
hair through so much i bleach it
i'm always like i cornrow just kidding
i bleach it i put clips in and stuff
like i really do
i put it i i put it to its limits and so
neutral has been really good for me to
kind of replenish the all of the
nutrients and stuff that it needs to
grow well the other thing i like about
it too is all the ingredients in it are
actually just like good vitamins that
you should be taking anyway and i have
dave on it i just ordered more for him
and he it i do see it really making a
difference in his hair because there was
some thinning and i feel like that has
completely listen and we don't listen if
you're going bald you're going bald but
if we can get your hair to come back
todd it has been such a treat todd has
an uncle scott that i am really hoping
he doesn't look like anytime soon
uncle scott i love you but that is a
rough ballpark scott we are sending you
some neutrophils we're getting a neutral
before they even sponsored us you told
me about them and i bought it because
there's a women formula in a men's
formula i got both you know because yeah
household and
anything that's actually not a gimmick
and that's healthy and vitamin focused
that will give you hair growth and make
you prettier
give it throw it in
we're not so connor okay we're not gonna
be balding it up it's like very few
people can pull off the bald look i
would like to see everyone in this room
in a bald cap you guys can grow thicker
and healthier hair and support our show
by going to nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is our best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get 15 off at
nutrafl.com annie can you spell that
no kalyla can you spell n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash trash at this point in my
life a day does not go by where i don't
down six of these
i
sorry i'm dehydrated now i'm a squirter
i feel like we've gotten so many people
we know hooked on liquid death
and like i don't have to feel bad about
that because it's actually good for the
environment to not use nasty plastic and
to use a can which you feel so classy
did you guys see they had a super bowl
commercial yeah i did see it it was
great with a pregnant woman drinking it
i was so honored i was like that's right
this is a cool look to carry around a
tall boy wherever i go is the look that
i want from us
in my life animator to a drawer i like
love the drawings that they have and
everything i just love the taste of
water in a can call me crazy no i think
it's really good it's like making water
cool it's like nobody wants to drink
water you never want to drink water yeah
it's boring
but it's like popping out hearing that
that crack open it feels naughty awesome
and yeah isn't recyclable anymore
and um most of plastic that you're using
eventually ends up in the landfill
and she is talking about her breast
implants
along with my breast implants
um you guys can get free shipping on all
water which is very
generous because water is expensive to
ship and merch at liquid death dot com
slash track that's liquid death dot com
slash trash or grab some at whole foods
sprouts and 7-eleven i love seeing i'm
seeing it popping up more and more
places but honestly the most convenient
way is just have it shipped to your
house at liquiddeath.com trash just get
some cases sent it's also a cute thing
sometimes i'll bring it if i'm going to
someone's house i'll just bring a case
of it and people like what is this and
like it's just water and it's like a
cute conversation piece it makes you
look cool in hot yoga too you're like
yeah look like you're just chugging
alcohol and hot yoga
um i just discovered something about
myself actually no i discovered this a
long time ago but i'm i'm now only brave
enough to say it
because it has been sort of this taboo
thing for a long time you [ __ ] your
brother
that's my point of taboo is this i think
but
when it comes to queefing
we've always had that moment of like
shame when it first happens
not anymore i think queefing feels so
[ __ ] good i've always thought this i
think when that air rolls out of the
[ __ ] that way
it feels it's like horses trampling
it's like a trot
so i've done this before and this is a
secret i've never told anybody i asked
guys to make me queef
no and if they don't like your waiters
or like
like george and carlos
so if they have they're having sex with
me from the back they have to pull their
dick all the way out and you know i
actually think that feels the best when
guys pull all the way out and back in
but it's danger zone because they could
cram into your [ __ ] accidentally it's
true it could also bend
yes yeah oh and the yeah can hurt their
dick it's dangerous for them too and i
like that or when girls your dick in
danger for me like when girls like are
on top and they go up too high
and crash down on half a [ __ ]
i honestly don't think i have my on top
game that good because i can do like
when my knees are when i'm like laying
on you on top but like you see the girls
that are like that are bouncing like
frog stuff yeah i even need a chair like
his todd's head would be like under here
but there's no i can't you know what i'm
talking about
i need help
wait getting on top is actually a very
delicate it's it's well you know what
i'm talking about when you're doing the
crouch that is like that is like maybe
you're meant for because your hips are
the age no my achilles are very asian
squat helps so i can do i can get on top
any which way i'm needed but
i want to put a mini cam on on a man's
face when a girl goes too high and is
about to crash on his half [ __ ]
it's like the face it's the same face
you see of the people that pass out when
they're going up on that one ride
where it crashes them down
they're like
present for this
you guys are some old hoes but i'm a pro
it's like old sperm you're like young
girls just get a face [ __ ] up you guys
opt in
can you guys please try just ask
ask to be queefed ask to
ask for the queef i'm telling you and
then think about it and sit with it
without the shame okay and it really
feels so should we try to record a queef
song where we all like our queefs kind
of like
come together to form some sort of
yankee doodle dandy
some sort of
it's like a feather in
that's what her hat
sounds like
she's coming
she's quivering all right so i do have
to tell you something three days ago
at 1205
pm
i squirted for the first time
i don't believe her i squirted all and i
caught it like i was squirting i was
like oh my god so i can't even imagine
what will happen
when i know the squirt's coming i am
confident in it we have
the tarp down
i need the play-by-play yeah okay so i
was okay so todd and i were banging
and then he came and right after he came
i had the
the [ __ ] tucker on
right after he pulled out
ever squirt came out so you need a [ __ ]
sucker you need i don't know what you
need this is what the vibe was thank you
for leaving carlos he doesn't like when
girls talk about having sex
because
it's unnatural for women to have sex for
women to jizz
but okay so i realize it's because
remember when we were talking about how
i cut we cover up when we come yeah i
was like i'm not gonna do that anymore
i'm gonna just be open and just like
surrender to it and i [ __ ] squirted
like a lot came out and it's not pee
were you trying to squirt like did it
happen on accident it was an accident it
was not on purpose i just was trying to
go with it and now what did it feel like
it felt great
was
it missing out was he no
it was sex and it didn't even
require we [ __ ] with his penis yeah
and then
never taking out he came on my stomach
yeah okay there was a quick towel to
catch it so it didn't drip in and get me
pregnant in the grossest most lame way
where it drips from your stomach into
the
[ __ ]
i always think about them like if that's
how i get pregnant a belly button baby
i will be so pissed
and then this is so gross i'm sorry you
guys are taking a lot better than my
family chat
but
i wanted to tell everyone i was so
excited and i just want you guys to know
that anything's possible you can do it
and i'm not sure if the levees have
broken i've been busy and on the road
and stuff so we haven't gotten to try
again look i feel so inspired
but also
fo mowed out of my mind i have never
squirted in my life you can you can you
just have to when you feel yourself
coming just like fully like surrender
just fully pee on him
push it out
it just i always feel like i'm close
though annie i always feel like i'm
close
and then nothing comes out so i feel
like the sensation of like the hotness
especially if like the g-spot is
stimulated but i cannot quite get there
yeah so i'm going to try the glitz
sucker and i tried when i went on the
road i brought it with me
and masturbating i couldn't i needed i
need times
i'm gonna need like
did you just say
it's asian that's what you call it
don't be racist learn asian culture i
did not know my
husband is not asian and i apologize
not yet again guys we have so much life
left
okay so i feel inspired i am going to
try that combo
and i'll let you know i'll report back
i'm so desperate to squirt i'm like
i honestly had to almost like bury it
and like let it not be a thing that was
ever gonna happen yeah yeah do you think
that it had to do with the fact that you
just surrendered and didn't cover up i
do think it did i think i was like it
was like a
push out vibe rather than a hold in okay
but then i know what you mean by that
yeah i want you to try if you guys both
do it then i will
i'll study this and it just sucks that
you bang on the couch why because you're
gonna squirt on your couch
i do this thing that i
like i feel like i
i feel like i surrender during sex but
there's one thing i do
that i'm kind of sad about which is i
always cover up my breasts ever since i
was younger and i don't know why well i
think i know why
i don't like the idea that like from
from where he's looking like my breasts
fall to the side a little bit so lucky
and i don't know if i like that look so
much so i always cover my breasts and
it's like the one thing that is like a
big barrier for me can i just tell you
how lucky you are that there's something
to fall all that happens is any meat
just goes down and there's just nipples
i have a full by the way do i not look
post or like i got top surgery in this
outfit this is top surgery outfit
i don't even know what you mean
someone transitions
it looks like i'm getting packs put on
right now
i have a pitch for you if that's an
issue is you should just if they fall to
the side just have sex in like a sexy
push-up bra i always have sex in a bra
oh okay that's been my problem like i
want to start having sex without a bra
and just say [ __ ] it how were they fall
sex is when i put my bra on it's the
only time i'm only wearing my projects
yeah so i need i need help with that
that is the one thing where i'm just
like when you had your big old fake
titties i covered them up too
i always wore a bra then you guys like
to come on your tits um they like to
come inside my [ __ ] oh
yeah cause you keep queefing on them
yeah jesus christ i guess i'll come in
our [ __ ]
yeah apparently they probably like that
because if it's on the menu everyone
goes for that that's the most it's the
most it's the delicacy when it's
available it's this is the evening
special when i got a colonoscopy the
doctor should have asked do you do anal
shut up
because i have um proctitis which is
like inflammation of like that area and
stuff he was like well there's two
reasons for this it could be like an
autoimmune thing or like how you know
like your sexual practices have you ever
used a butt plug because
one of my friends um
he said that like that's what you do if
you're gonna bottom like you do a butt
plug for like five days before i didn't
know really to stretch it yeah which i'm
like is he lying to me wait butt plugs
are like spacers like that yeah
like people's ears like the emo kids
here that's what he said but then i i
and i'm like well i guess that makes
sense what else would they be for i'm
sorry but
the [ __ ] is a high traffic area yeah
you [ __ ] big shits it can take a lot
it is meant to be to
take a lot of
i don't enjoy it either i think when i
was younger i just thought that i would
somehow be remembered as the girl who
was just the freak and let me do anal
and i always like took pride in that now
i'm just like no entry damn they called
[Laughter]
i did have a friend um she's a beauty
queen but she
likes to strictly be [ __ ] in the ass
it is her thing i swear to god like i've
seen that girl like fart out a whole
cheeto like that's how much what do you
mean by fart out a cheeto like we were
on the dance floor once and like i just
think that her ass has just been
compromised how do you know because she
just that's her preferred place to
receive penetration is she gassy she is
always gassy i remember we were going
salsa dancing and i'm like why is this
dance for dance floor smell so bad you'd
think it would be less like fart because
fart really needs the quiver the
sphincter oh yeah like without the like
if it's a loose [ __ ] you'd think the
fart just
i just think that this you kind of need
to be like
well no that i think that makes it like
the the it can just free-flow out all
night it's just diarrhea smelling yeah
i mean look i think this sphincter maybe
it gets aired out more because the air
good air is going in
oh or maybe it wasn't hers and i was
blaming the wrong person maybe her
[ __ ] is still frog tight i don't know
but i all i know is every time i'm
around her i smell like a cloud
and i have this need to ask her like if
she even handled it are frogs the gold
standard type
it's watertight they're in the they're
amphibious
i don't know about amphibians
[Laughter]
and or dayquil and i i'm not quite sure
what i was about to take adderall with
this
i feel like oh
it is but you know i think that you're
annie letterman and
let it ride
rock it out you may know me from
bragging about special
okay snorting adderall at taco bells
down the road and being an icon of
sobriety since 2009.
you were in the news i saw you in the
news and people have been asking me
about it you were in the news no it's so
horrible and stupid basically was
insinuating that i was sliding into the
dms of a british dj
which i didn't even know there was such
a thing as a famous british dj also they
must not whoever did this must not know
you at all
like that is not a dj
[ __ ] about a dj off from what you'd be
interested in
yes there's that's why there was no
reason for me to even call it mail
like if it was a female dj i'd be like
oh my god esther like samantha ronson or
somebody oh that would be good i believe
that's juicy yeah
and i what's so [ __ ] up is i called
dave
and i told him about it
and he didn't believe that the post was
about me i had to convince him
that it was that they were talking about
me and he said this doll face it
literally is a dollar it's gonna be a
bloodbath bloodbath female comedian
podcaster but yeah no it was a weird
feeling it definitely gave me anxiety
because i it was the first time where
like
something was someone was talking about
me
and like i wasn't a part of it because
i'm so sad to tell you yesterday it's
not the first time the minute you leave
early we are trashing you the entire
time but you know what i mean like we do
with this podcast we're in control of it
we we tweet our stand-up you do tiger
belly it's like
when have you ever like been looking at
news and you see someone saying about
something about something about you that
is so
stupid and not true and then there's
people who believe it and who are
messaging me and commenting and it's
like
it was i felt like freaked out by it but
i obviously also think it's kind of
funny and kind of cool no i was like yes
[ __ ] you were so awesome you really
helped me because you said like this is
a good thing and whitney too like you
guys had like good like positive girl
girl power spins on it of like no this
is a good thing like people are talking
about you but there was a moment where i
was like
what the [ __ ] well it's annoying to be
like have something that's not true and
you can't you're not really able to
clear it up exactly
like and i'm never gonna respond to that
[ __ ] like i don't i don't care what they
say i'm never engaging i don't wanna i
just don't wanna play that game i'm
never responding to anyone that says can
i walk you to your truck
um
i'll never respond to any peach emojis
um
what do you guys think of
me wanting to possibly get married in a
cemetery
i think it's on brain yeah you do look
like the chick from the skeleton what
the corpse bride doesn't she look at the
club's bread
thank you for casting me yeah
i think it's a compliment i
i just feel like we're not utilizing
cemeteries as beautiful parks as much as
we can i feel like i feel like also
could be a
you could get a good value you know
maybe a good price
for it i'll make you a deal
annie and i have to choose the cemetery
yeah we have to choose here getting
married at a top
and it's going to be it's not going to
be one of your hollywood cemetery fancy
places we get to choose it well wait now
all i want to do is do a live show and a
cemetery with you guys okay can we do
that yeah i um
not available
even if i were um to say okay
that sounds like a cool idea and even
though i'm not catholic anymore i still
have that catholic fear and i think i'd
be taking on um bad juju if i were to
just um do anything why'd you have to
bring up the kids
can i that's true can i start can i
encounter you
i believe
that it's actually polite
and positive to spend time in the
cemetery because if there really are
souls there they're lonely and they
would love to have life
be a part of
their
existence if i saw three
old [ __ ]
tap dancing around my dad's grave
for a live stream
you're right i'd be okay it'll be
awesome
yeah yeah like i
i love going to cemeteries my favorite
is westwood cemetery um it's that's
where marilyn is
um
why'd you whisper in it yeah you know
i'm just just being casual um truman
capote
there's so many iconic legends and it's
such a small cemetery that like you can
kind of see everybody
and it's just to me it's a beautiful
pleasant park whenever i have visitors
in town i take them there it's like are
you kidding me and who are your visitors
they're your parents yeah acting like
you have other visitors who are your
visitors mom and dad
i always take them to the cemetery
it is true well you're like you'll be
here soon
it's so rude to take old people to a
cemetery
maybe kids to do the kids think it's fun
they do the crayon rubbings and stuff i
mean my dad
martin fan i took him to meet dean
martin i think i think i'm a good
kid he's a dean martin fan i think
carlos is too if you know what i mean
and same so is james kennedy
so i think thing
like dean are you calling yourself gay
oh no this is my new thing this is her
new thing and she she traps us
um i'm so excited about living proof i
know i use it all the time it's my
number one brand no i know i have their
shampoo i have their dry shampoo the dry
shampoo there's no other dry shampoo i
use it doesn't work i would i mean i go
through a canister in a day i love it
it's so good and also like i
whenever i talk to like celebrity hair
stylist they always are using the living
proof dry shampoo on me they're like
this is the one it actually works it
smells good it's not too strong
i have been using living proof for years
it's so good so imagine how excited i
think annie is just as excited i've been
using it for years i couldn't believe it
they were like oh living proof when
bryce told me living proof i was like
shut up what are the products i always
do with the dry shampoo and then the
perfect hair day shape yes
also the best conditioner if you have
fine hair like me they have a
conditioner that just makes really like
full and fluffy and light and ugh i'm so
happy i also really like the packaging
like the gray it's so chic it just makes
me feel like
oh i must be like i must be star starlet
i just have gotten listen i've gotten
dry shampoos before and i know that i'm
like pimping out the dry but i'm telling
you their dry shampoo is like unmatched
i have tried every dry shampoo and it
doesn't work like i remember thinking is
dry shampoo fake what is it like should
i just use baby powder or something and
then i got living proof and i will spend
my life on it i don't care same they
could raise their prices raise their
prices
what's slowly don't raise your prices
that is very affordable i never used to
think conditioner mattered i was like
well it's just a detangler it's just
this and that it's the when i go diving
my hair is a matted mess afterwards it's
the only conditioner that actually
detangles my hair it's a lifesaver i
highly recommend you guys we want you to
put science to work and unlock your best
hair with living proof go to living
proof dot com slash tuesday and use code
tuesday to get 10 off your first
purchase that's livingproof.com
tuesday code tuesday for 10 off your
first purchase livingproof.com tuesday
code tuesday and comment below and
comment on our instagram after you get
it and tell me how dope that dress yeah
because you're gonna love it i swear
i am i
feel you on the cemetery i spent most of
my birthdays growing up in a cemetery
this is part of the abuse i suffered but
um
so november 1st um
november 1st similar to like dia de los
muertos filipinos also celebrate that so
like that whole week of november 1st you
don't have school
you it's like a national holiday but you
spend one or two days
um you bring booze you bring food you
bring it to the cemetery over the what
do you call it the
the grave stone
and then you drink and then you party
with you know the disease i love that
because it really is like or do we have
to do that we'll do it i love that
whoever dies first we're going to party
on your yeah no oh speaking of who's
already gone speaking of the departed um
do we have an update on our buddy here's
the thing i went to i i went to his his
facebook and stuff and unfortunately his
band his cover brand hadn't taken off
too much so
there weren't that many posts about it
yeah but there was a memorial on the
sixth and i just couldn't i couldn't
make it and also i was thinking about it
he
he blocked me okay oh he did he blocked
me back in the day and it's like he if
he didn't want me in life he doesn't
want me in death and i wanted to respect
that i was also tired i'd flown in that
day but it just like if i show up and
i'm like i'm a figure
you know like what you know but i'm i'm
guessing it was a drug situation i don't
really know how he died but i'm also
like i should think i should be okay
with not knowing i really want to just
throw you
some respect and compliments
that you knew
that because he had blocked you in life
that he wouldn't want you there he
doesn't want me in there because i feel
like everyone has been at a funeral
where there is that one person where
you're like
they shouldn't be here yep and they're
usually very chatty
and sometimes they're in a puka shell
necklace
but i just have i have a distinct memory
at a funeral our friend angelo bowers
and there was some guy there who just
stole the spotlight and we were all like
who the [ __ ] is this guy come on man
so i think you did the right thing
because well i was gonna be inquired
like i was there to get some intel too
you know like yes celebrate though he
was really like he was like a friendly
cool guy if you were going for intel now
i think you did the wrong thing i know
but i you i wasn't going to be able to
hang well it would have been like so
obvious i would have my hair extensions
in there like who is like dressing up
wait do we know where he's buried and
can we offer him a candle and a quiz now
oh maybe we should go bring that's a
great idea just yeah i think i could
find out i could dm someone and just be
like hey this is the situation yeah i
can find out some stuff i just i'm
always like i when someone dies usually
like a public figure dies or someone we
know dies i'm always like on that that
like
detective hunt to find out how they died
and it's so [ __ ] disrespectful it
really is like not my business it's i've
had to really stop myself from doing
that because that that is also my first
instinct it's like i cannot just go to
bed at night thinking someone has passed
i need to know exact details of how they
pass what they were doing who they were
with who they chatted with last there's
anything wrong with that i think it
makes sense it's disrespectful to
inquire is what annie is saying to like
how how did they pass it's like it's
it's not my life so it's like if the way
that they died if it doesn't like appear
to me in front of me if i'm doing the
search it's like nosy it's not
it's not for any but i think it's i
think the reason we do that is like a
common human like need to want to know
yes like that's what it's almost like
protection wanting to know like what
should i not do or is there something i
can to me this is like a good example of
how we're all just animals and it's like
we want to know what happened to the
other animals that were
like i always think when when i'm on a
plane and it's turbulent and it feels
under getting fingered i'm always like
oh my cervix
and it feels scary
but you know it's safe because
turbulence is totally safe but the
animal in me is like i don't like how
this feels bumping in the air like i
think the animal in you is like what
happened to him right isn't that fair i
think that it's normal to feel that way
but it can be it can backfire because
for me what happens is how many more
cautionary tales do i need to tell
myself let's say the person died being
run over on so and so bridge that's
another anxiety and fear i'm implanting
in my head like
where it's like
or even if he had died a covet or this
and that like i i now have i'm added on
to the whole pile of waste to die
and you know that was the great show do
you remember that show when you felt
like that was wasted oh yeah oh
no it was that's awesome it was so funny
so bad for anxiety oh god
but it was like i think about like with
bob saget where it was like
we didn't know he died
[Music]
what i think this is a perfect time for
a banana break yeah talking about also
imagine how
how painful it already is for his family
and then people really just prying into
how the specifics of how he died in his
autopsy report all the while they're
already feeling
the bad moment of their life is their
death it's not like especially when it's
shocking like that yeah
you guys are right but i wouldn't beat
yourself up for oh i still find out yeah
what i'll usually do is wait for the one
idiot in the comment section to be like
how do you die and then look for that
for answers oh yeah but i'll go
8 000 comments deep to find that one
person wait what happened and then
someone's you know usually gives the
answer i could not find that's why i was
like i'm just gonna guess it was
like drugs or suicide or something but
he was a nice guy and it was it was nice
to kind of like remember
how nice he was like looking at people's
comments and stuff when i found out my
old boss died i was like uh johnny
rockets no
though that lady the lady babysitter
i like had to know what happened i just
and i found and it was
yeah
she hung herself it was not good
all right i have to bring up a brody
thing which is i know we don't like to
on that transition you guys let's see
suicides i had a psychic
uh-oh that lived next to me this girl
and she she was like
she would it started to get really kind
of like creepy i kind of want to write a
horror movie about it like she just it
started to be like she'd be like don't
walk i'd be like i'm going to go walk to
backsliders don't walk there i'm like
what why does anybody get hit by a car
or something like shut up
so like things like that but then she
goes your friend brody it was like right
around the time when brodia died
and i am guilty of like talking to
people just talking at people like
needing someone to just like be the body
next to me that i just talked to and it
always backfires they always come for me
i'm just like talk talk and then
something happens oh
oh my god i'm spilling my
day quill
anyway
so she said to me she's like your friend
brody has a message do you want to hear
it and i go okay can i this is someone
with many catchphrases
so i'm like sure go can i get was the
message please give carlos the
sweatshirt of my back that you ruined
the sweatshirt you immediately got
makeup on
so what was it she goes here's the
message okay and this is our friend okay
we know how our friend talks we know his
cadence we know his catchphrases
she goes he just wants to let you know
he loves you you're such a talent he
wants you to keep it's like
never in a million years would his
message be about me
about him
[Laughter]
i was like take a take a little gander
on google [ __ ] there's like so many
catchphrases he could have said
if she said his catchphrase was eight
one he wanted to get you a message eight
one eight i would have been like oh my
god yeah
i don't know if you see this red dot on
my forehead it's not a bendy i'm not
culturally appropriating
this is thank god
i
i've had a bump on my forehead that i
thought in the beginning was a zit and i
was like i don't know if it's a zit it's
not popping i go oh i got a weird thing
i'm going to go to a dermatologist
avoiding it avoiding it
todd the other day goes let me pop that
sit on your forehead i go it's not a zit
and he goes let me just try and he
[ __ ]
dr pimple poppered my [ __ ] forehead
in a way that like this man made me
squirt out of my [ __ ] and out of my
forehead
i'm so
like grateful for him i keep looking at
him and being like thank you even i have
a scar for the rest of my life it's like
i can't believe it happened and then i
started watching dr pimple popper after
it because it was so
exciting i was so sure it wasn't as it
so now i used to not be able to watch it
if you can just sit through a couple of
them
you can get through all of them what is
the point of that wait what isn't the
point of that
yeah it's joy you want to have a wedding
on top of the dead
esther you don't you don't um enjoy
extractions of any kind like earwax
extractions or i get it ingrowns
i get it i love i love
an ingrown on my body to come out i love
a friend oh six hairs out of one pore
oh wow just that'll make me come when
it's a long curly one you're like oh my
god oh my god and then more and more
come out but even hearing the stories on
dr pimple pop i'm like that thing could
have turned into a horn
but people do have horns what
yeah yeah horns are a real thing no
they're not what people can't get horns
they're called horns actually phil i
have a horn feel this yeah
oh i have a bump
they said it's just like calcium
deposits what
what did you feel on her head people
have horns
how
oh
sorry no
yeah i don't know if this is real those
are real what is causing that
a lot of things i mean have you heard of
stone babies no no oh god you're gonna
have a good time pull them up carlos
doesn't sound like it stone babies are
similar to an experienced ester head
are usually babies that go undetected
like for instance a woman is pregnant
but she doesn't know she's pregnant it
either becomes an ectopic pregnancy but
over time instead of delivering the baby
her body just rejects it and it it um it
comes out her skin no it surrounds like
it becomes a calcium deposit and it
becomes this stone baby that they have
inside of them
yeah that's your stone baby
now i had been saying a while ago i
wanted to talk about the movie old oh
god i watched it did you watch it isn't
it so
upsetting
it's upsetting because i just found it
to be such a you could clearly tell it
was shot during covet like pete coveted
premise wise it was really good
i just hated the movie besides that it
didn't bring me any
yeah
explain to master
okay so spoiler if you guys haven't seen
the mni charmlon movie
it's like this island that people go to
and they
something with the
magnetic forces or something makes them
age like their whole lives in one day
so
yeah so like the you know they some guy
went with his mom his mom died almost
immediately then everyone's just aging
rapidly and it's just so
it just made me feel so much why what
did it mean well just the whole point
was like it would be like you know this
couple came on the island and they were
fighting and then it's like they grow
old with their kids grow up and their
kids are sitting next to them and
they're just like what were we fighting
about like the whole it's like a little
on the nose but
it just was really
i thought that it could have been a
really good movie just like the premise
of it was kind of cool but it just was
just [ __ ] weird what would make
people want to go to that island no they
were bamboozled to enter because it was
it became like the scientific it was a
it was uh like an experimental site
right yeah um
and they would bring people that had
like an ailment they were just seeing if
they could cure the if they could cure
them
yeah of their diseases
in theory interesting just poor
execution it was just really
esther have you ever heard of a teratoma
speaking of stone babies yes
what is that
it's basically like an evil twin living
inside you
a slow yes is enough i've heard the word
okay that's and that's
what that counts for something terra
cotta there's a lot of things that sound
like it's i like to call it like an evil
twin living inside of you and that might
be annie you're third
you're thinking
a triplet and that's what this is this
is so
it's like a tumor with teeth
right it could be like it could almost
be like look like a formed human but
just very small and kind of just living
in you
like a but there's a whole movie around
this it's called i don't want another
spoiler alert but it's called malignant
um but
better than old huh who's in it god
who's in malignant i forget but please
watch that movie if you're into
territories
is all i'll say is it because the kid
the other baby's territorial
well like
i don't want to give it away
is it possible that
annie is a terror
is that why you keep bringing it up
i'm bigger than you
esther you would be the size of a
teratoma oh you are like thank you so
much everyone is always like how tall is
esther when i meet them and it's like i
don't even know how to explain it
because i'm shocked every time i see you
but we should just tell people the size
of a stone baby well sometimes it's the
same size as a stone baby guys we gotta
go to vegas we gotta go to vegas
i need our show in vegas what would we
do well kala what would we do in vegas
is there like god we're leaving it up to
me again no no no no no no no no no
we're not leaving it ever again that's
never happening
that was not okay i'm leaving it up to
kale no
i think you your idea of just doing
shows and eating nice things and
gambling and he likes to gamble i think
that's fun could we like get us like a
nice sweet yes
in vegas
and just like
get high and i don't know just see what
see where the mood takes us i think we
just remember there the tensions may get
high but we like that we want to
remember that's good content but we
don't want to shy away from it we don't
need self-care on this trip oh my god oh
my god that's terrifying go in it and
then we take a couple weeks off my hands
are already sweating but what if we but
what if we did like we did it when we
had already banked a bunch so we knew we
could get some time off so it could be
like an intense a goodbye day
it's a it's planned so that we don't
speak for a month yeah yeah yeah you
gotta decompress i think if we do like
three days which i think is so long
that's so long in vegas but i think we
should dedicate an esther day and annie
day and a kalila day so it's like one
day we do everything you want to do
esther the shows like we want to see
save up your money for any day
save your cash for any day because we're
gambling all day baby i'm going to start
smoking again
yeah so let's do that and so there's no
confusion and then we just
part waste and then take a month we're
gonna take a month off okay i wanna i
wanna know what are some things for that
you guys would wanna do on each of your
days because i know mine is so easy i
would want to see a concert i would want
to eat a really nice sushi dinner
and i definitely would want the concert
to be in the same venue where we're
sleeping
and
walk walk walk get your exercise in go
to a couple sephoras there's like four
on the strip and then we all like taken
edible we stay up all night
and just have fun chatting
um
a kalila day would be uh we go to
red the red rocks we'd go gone a couple
nice hikes love it we go look for
petrified wood highly available
or a stone baby
we'd maybe go bring the speculum
we'd maybe go to see the colorado river
on a boat
esther might be like i don't want to be
on a boat i get seasick and it's not she
definitely gets seasick i definitely do
but for kalyala day we'll we'll get
dramamine and we'll prepare i'll also
have make sure that the boat has like
coverage so you don't get like a sunburn
or anything okay okay
um so more of that stuff is what i like
and then we're gonna be in a [ __ ]
smoke-filled casino all day
it's gonna be so fun we're eating the
edibles in the morning we're not we're
not waiting till the night okay
we're gonna be [ __ ] up all day if you
guys want to drink drink like anything
you want to do we're doing it in excess
okay okay i can i can hang with that
yeah
party vegas kalila is
i want to meet your friends yeah i
forgot about my day has to be we have to
have a strip club on my door okay
every night yes every night that's just
part of my day your day all i'm gonna
say is we're oh for 20 at this point but
the amount of times we mentioned going
to a circle that's never happened
and carlos went once we did but then oh
you didn't get in we yeah we couldn't
get in for certain reasons
we can't say it on the show carlos
wouldn't take his hat off
but we were so close carlos we could we
could smell the [ __ ]
the gravy
baby the baby oil and [ __ ] yeah no that
the i always what my rhinestone
strippers is that like sweet well i
can't remember but there's like a
dessert smelly i know you're talking
it's pink it's they sell it at sephora
is it escada
no no whitney had it too yeah pink sugar
something like that yeah now okay wait
so we're gonna do that we're gonna go to
the buffet and get crab legs i'm down
for that buffet every day buffet is like
heaven
i mean i'm not against a cirque du
soleil i always like to watch to see if
maybe someone will fall
but um
i don't know like
yeah it'll be late night i want to go on
that the ferris wheel
with new york new york the ferris wheel
or the roller coaster they have the
fires the ferris wheels the one outside
you get a cupcake from the they have the
the cupcake sprinkles oh yes the
and can we take ecstasy on your day
um yeah but we have to make sure our
gambling's through okay cause you don't
want to distract yourself from the most
fun thing in the world oh are we gonna
do slot machines yes mitch we're gonna
do blackjack slot machines and roulette
is there anything better than the
thought of us three in vegas it's so fun
we're elderly-ish too we'll wear like
vibes can i propose something too can we
go um
sort of closer to the summer like
between the cusp of spring and summer
because there's just way hotter guys
there sure yeah so we'll also we should
get hall passes oh my god annie todd
will never give me one hall passes i i
use mine on youtube
[Laughter]
hers doesn't leave the hotel room
what um is there a bobo update
um he's home oh good
and um he's you know he's doing better
good yeah
okay yeah um
well
ladies it has been a lovely time see you
guys next week
we'll see you next week thank you guys
and um subscribe baby let us know if you
have ideas for our vegas trip let us
know what else do we talk about today
look listen here's what we learned
queefs feel good yes squirting is
possible at any age
i'm gonna try so hard this week i think
you can do it you have to release it's
the less trying it's like that i think i
need you in my ear yeah so when i'm
close to coming i'm just going to be the
one manually doing it
look if it's got to be me it's got to be
me get me there baby get me there you
guys we're trying to get to 200k
subscribers and you better [ __ ] get
us there or annie's gonna beat me up i'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of her please
like this video comment subscribe we
love you and we will see you next week
bye guys
[Music]
you